Whats up my friends of youtube
Grant jumping in here with a subscriber appreciation
I picked up a Galaxy S9 plus smartphone that I am going to give one of you.
Link's in the description, go put your name on the list and I'll see you around
Hey Guys! We're back in the kitchen and if you are a long time fan of The King of Random
You may recognize the clear glue and Borax that Grant used to make Ninja Turtle Ooze
several years ago. Today we're going to be mixing up a few batches of that and as an added twist, we're going to
see if we can make it Glow in the Dark
using the fluid from Glow Sticks. We've got clear glue and we've got Borax and we've got about 30 glow sticks that
we are going to tear open and extract the fluid out of and see if we can make a glowing, gooey ooze.
The first step is going to be opening all of these glow sticks and separating out the activator fluid and the dye fluid into individual bowls.
the reason we've got our glow sticks separated like this is because we're going to try to get five different colors of our glowing ooze. a red, an orange, a yellow-ish green, a fairly blue, and something of a purple.
(royalty free music)
With all 5 colors of our glow stick fluid separated, it's time
to mix up five batches of our ooze recipe. To do that we take one cup of water mixed with
one half teaspoon of Borax
and then in a separate bowl we have
one half cup of water mixed with five ounces of this clear school glue.
once we have all those ready
We'll add the separate components of the glow stick fluid into the two halves and then once we mix them together
hopefully we get an amazing glowing ooze.
(royalty free music)
Now that we have our five separated halves of our ooze recipe, let's add the separated halves of the glow stick fluid into them
We'll put all of the dye in the side with the borax
and we'll put all of the activator in the side with the glue.
That's interesting, it's turning a very milky white.
The dye doesn't seem like it's really mixing in at all though, it's kind of just getting mixed around, but not combining. We'll see if this will work, maybe it will just stay separated out more than we want it to.
Hitting each of these with a black light we can see the color that they are going to fluoresce if everything goes to plan.
We've got a bright red-ish pink, a nice highlighter orange, a very vibrant yellow, a nice Avatar glowing blue, and a sort of purple-ish pink
it's not violet per say but it definitely has a purple-ish tinge to it.
This is the moment of truth, we have to see two things, one, if the two sides of the glow fluid will combine and start
putting off light the way we hope it will, and two, it's also possible the glow fluid itself will prohibit the reaction that normally turns into the ooze and we're hoping that's not going to happen
but let's find out!
We'll start down here at the pink or magenta end, and we'll hope there is enough space in these bowls to hold all of our liquid.
Kinda give it a stir as I pour it in to get as much of the glow fluid in as possible
Ooh! I think I see some glowing! (wierd singing voice)
Woo! Ahh!
Alright, that's getting everywhere.
(plays with ooze)
This looks really cool!
It's interesting because the farther in the ooze you see, the more it seems to glow,
so the outside barely seems like its giving off light but its like the inside is,
Yeah look at this, if I poke a hole down into it, it's like glowing more down inside the hole.
Well I think we need to mix up our other colors!
(even more royalty free music)
Woah! That looks so cool! It looks like lava!
That looks so cool!
Look at that! Lava ooze!
It looks kind of like a nebula in space.
It's kind of funny when I fold it over more of the color comes out like it looks pretty blue when it's flat
and then I fold it, and then you see a little bit more of the pink in there.
Guys, this stuff is ooey and it's gooey and slimy and oozy, and it's glowing and this is so fun looking!
Woobly Woobly Woobly!
This stuff is amazing, there is one more thing I really think we need to try and that's just sort of combining it into one, giant "Oooberblob" of glowing ooze.
Ahhh! Ahaha!
Giant blob of glowing ooze!
Oh now it's running off my hands
I'm not doing anything with it so it's just starts puddling and running.
in like a rainbow of glowing colors.
I'm not going to do that.
I know what glow fluid tastes like and it's disgusting, so I am not going to put any of this in my mouth.
This just looks like a living creature now
It's a very short glowing orange poop emoji
that didn't really work
Oh no!!
It's hard juggling things that come apart in your hands.
*smack*
Hey what's up guys Grant here with a brand new Galaxy S9 Plus smartphone that I am giving away to one of you
for subscriber appreciation, I've got a link down in the description so you can get your name on the list, and qualify to win.
*smack*